ready okay awesome so uh great so for
our next talk we have George here to
tell us about what statistics we can
multi-calibrate uh excited to hear this
talk uh
thanks thanks for having me yeah
um I'm gonna tell you yesterday about
um an overall picture of what you can do
with multi-calibration when you're
interested in eliciting various
statistics
um on your data set
and sort of the goals of today's talk
are first to
delaying age
um sort of the scope of
multi-calibration what it can and what
it can't do this is all too easy to
assume but you know any statistics that
we want to elicit yeah should be
possible to elicit because why not right
turns out this is not true then also I
want to sort of introduce all of us to
this connection between uh you know the
subject of this workshop and another
research area called property
elicitation which I believe has lots of
potential in terms of helping us Advance
our multi-group cause
and third
um I want to say that um
since lots of focus has been placed
historically on the binary case right
where uh labels are zero and one
um
one thing has been left out of the
picture and this is the fact that
um if you actually have a more complex
label space then
um the repository of risk measures that
or statistics or properties I'm using
these terms synonymously today that you
might want to use in various settings
right to elicit something about the data
set that you actually want to know is
vast and some of these as we'll see
today
will have these nice multi-volved
properties and some won't so it's very
important I think that we begin a
principled study of uh various such risk
measures
so yeah this is this is what we are
doing here and I want to say that uh
most of the focus has been on
multi-valid estimation of label means
but recently and Chris gave an excellent
talk yesterday
um
we've also done something nice with
quantiles
um in fact right the control production
papers have uh multi-value quantile
regression sort of like in the
background right and today we'll talk
about what else we can multi-calibrate
essentially property elicitation uh has
a growing collection of tools that
should help us reason uh simultaneously
about statistics that we're interested
in in our data as well as loss functions
that we can minimize in order to elicit
those statistics as accurately as
possible so thank empirical risk
minimization right and actually
um there's lots of nice econ CS
connections to property elicitation so
these proper losses uh product should
mention in the stock very briefly
actually have these nice truthfulness
properties that you know like
subcontract a self-interested third
party and pay them according to such
loss functions and they'll be
incentivized to reveal their knowledge
about the corresponding statistics
truthfully so lots of nice things so
let's study that
Okay so
this I'm just going to briefly skim over
so we have a data set of feature label
pairs coming from some underlying
distribution
um and the most traditional setting is
to assume that
um the label space y just consists of
two elements and then
um the Bayes optimal predictor will just
give the probability that the coin is up
heads for every individual X and we want
to get as close to that predictor as
possible while enforcing calibration
constraints over an arbitrarily Rich
family of groups okay so and this is
this is what we mean here
um and I'm going to continue using this
very informal notation throughout the
talk
um yeah okay
so
as I just mentioned in the binary
prediction setting the ground truth is
basically just a scalar corresponding to
each individual in the data right each
element of the future space that's
pretty much everything that there is to
know about anyone's individual
distribution right so it would be
pointless to talk about you know various
risk measures on
um Bernoulli distributions now as soon
as we go to multi-class settings
especially for you know higher numbers
of classes or the regression setting
suddenly many of these statistics start
being interesting and we really want to
know what to do with them okay
so this is this is sort of a line of
work that we've been doing uh in our
group and uh yeah I hope I hope to sort
of like promote it once again here and
today I'll sort of talk about the bird's
eye view of this entire line of work
minus the experimentation uh that was
done in some of the prior papers making
it practical
okay and
let me sort of recap The Story So Far So
multi-calibrated means
should satisfy this condition and
um as as we talked about plan T during
this Workshop so far uh what you do is
you keep checking the following
condition over various group value pairs
so like on each group and for each value
in the range of the current predictor
you check if the expected distance
between your predictions on the true
label is uh non-negligible and if you
find something like this you fix it and
you move on until hopefully this
converges and it does because we can use
the squared loss as a nice potential
function okay
so
um let's think about this very
instructive case of trying to
multi-calibrate variances right so in
principle I could write down
the analogous definition uh just like
for means right we want to ensure that
the conditional variance given that
we're predicting a certain value for the
variance and X belongs to some group uh
should be equal to that value so without
any further squinting this looks
reasonable but then if you start trying
to come up with an actual algorithm to
enforce this you'll quickly find out
that there isn't an obvious candidate to
replace this condition that we're
checking throughout the mean multi
calibration algorithm and we might
wonder okay is this is this some sort of
coincidence are we just not being
creative enough uh or what not so then
we can go back to the fundamentals and
we can be like okay let's at least check
that the ground truth which we are in
the pursuit of approximating can in fact
satisfy these conditions and for those
of you who haven't seen this results it
might sound a little surprising at first
but actually uh they're very simple
counter examples for when you cannot
have this property be satisfied even by
the base optional predictor right so
let's say our entire universe consists
of two individuals and one of them has
label one deterministically and one is
labeled zero deterministically okay so
Point wise the base optimal variance
predictor says zero
however now this predictor only has one
level set and that's where it predicts
zero our entire data set so if we now
take any mixture with non-zero weights
of both of these individuals it's clear
that the variance will not be zero and
so we cannot actually have multiplicity
in the sense that we try to have it okay
so very simple counter example yep a new
uh sort of put that for a second
so you're saying that uh
that sort of at least the syntactic
definition like transporting the
syntactic definition of mean
multi-calibration to an analogous thing
for
variance
does not make sense in the sense of like
the true variance function effect the
variance of each individual
conditioned on the individual what's
their variance you're saying they're
both zero here but but if you take a
mixture over them experiences
right yeah so so the conditional
distribution that we're interested in
having the varians equals our prediction
is a mixture over the individuals with
you know whatever probabilities these
individuals occur in the data sets so
yeah this like syntactic transformation
leads to a nonsensical result and uh you
know it's it's unclear what else we
could we could uh Define for appearances
that would be interesting yeah to derail
you but could you just really quickly
Flash the last definition the variance
so so the definition is literally that
um I'm conditioned unconditionally
labels on the event that I'm predicting
a certain value uh
um yeah remember that's yeah
that's right so F throughout the talk is
whatever we're trying to predict um for
each X right let's hope the groups are
you and Aaron isn't the variance so the
group so I'm just I'm just saying that
like Aaron and I are one entire group so
I'm here I'm just arguing that even
calibration is impossible so yeah good
points so what I'm saying today uh is
actually like facts about calibration to
which you can add on whatever groups you
want to condition on without any harm to
um the claims that I'm making sorry um
calibration
yeah so but calibration I mean
multi-calibration multi calibration
where I I don't even want to consider
any special group structure just one to
consider like this marginal case right
so here I only have one group which is
everything that they had a set I'm
trying to adjust condition on my
predictive values yeah without any
further conditioning right so this could
also be named multivariants and
multivariants
uh so it would be multi if there were
like for like partitions and two groups
I guess is what's very multi would mean
so apparently just calibrated variance
is impossible but also multivariants is
impossible
um okay so
um the paper that I've worked out the
mean variance case actually made the
following points that we cannot
calibrate variance by itself but
variants if you were if you happen to
know that let's say
um you're currently in the level set of
your data set where everyone's label
mean is some fixed value right so maybe
maybe like all the individuals that
you're looking at currently have
probability of success like 0.6 right so
the condition on that variance actually
distributes linearly across these
individuals so it starts behaving like
uh just like any other linear property
in particular like means so
um the approach then is to basically say
okay it suffices to get a mean
multi-calibrated prediction for your
means and then since variance is a
linear condition on that let's just take
let's just take uh the same mean multi
calibration algorithm right because
there's a linear you know well we can
like imagine some pseudo-labels right
that you know these like variances
generate and then you keep sort of
cycling through these two steps until
conversions and it also happens okay so
so from here we might suspect that
linearity is something super important
so linear properties are good to go
non-linear properties are in need of
some like linearizing property right so
this is what might we might suspect but
actually this is not quite true because
these most multi-valid conformal
prediction papers actually produce
multi-value quantiles and quantiles are
in general non-linear so if you just
take any two distributions that don't
necessarily have equal 0.9 quantiles
then you cannot just mix them together
in any proportionate hope that the mixed
distribution will have the same quantile
value so actually we can calibrate both
linear and non-linear properties but
then some properties are impossible to
calibrate by themselves so what's going
on right okay and
um
how do you calibrate quantiles and this
will give us another lead here we
actually replace the condition that
we're checking for means that the
expected difference in predictions and
true labels is close to zero we replace
it by this coverage condition so since
we're trying to produce let's say 0.9
quantiles then our predictor f of x is
supposed to cover the true label with 90
probability conditional on group value
intersections okay so this is a direct
analogy right and you know once again we
just we say that we want this definition
of calibration for quantiles just
replace means with quantiles when you
plug in variance here it didn't work but
for quantize it does work
okay so the main part of my talk and
it's really great that I've gotten to it
so you know that's you know if there's
one thing that I want to tell it's it's
this one so
um
we will start by proving that the Bayes
optimal predictor so without yet
considering algorithmic
um implications of this the base Optical
predictor for a property is calibrated
if and only if the property itself has
convex level sets and what do I mean by
this so a property in today's talk is a
functional that takes as inputs a
distribution and outputs a single real
valued number okay and so uh it's level
sets will actually consist of families
of distributions right so a level set
for any value that you want to take will
be all distributions such that their
property gamma is equal to V and then
having convex level sets means that if
you take any two members of that level
set you combine them with
um any weights and it stays within that
same level set okay so you combine two
distributions with this same property
value and it yields the same property
value
and in particular linear properties
satisfied us but this is weaker than the
linear condition because here we're only
requiring this linear condition to hold
when both of the distributions we're
combining have the same value right
linearity would mean that they don't
necessarily have the same value okay
so the first direction is uh very easy
and what we observe is simply that if we
try to take
our conditional distribution over
anywhere that the Bayes optional
predictor predicts V we're essentially
taking a mixture of conditional
distributions y given X over some subset
of those X for which their individual
property value is equal to
Z okay so this is essentially going to
be a conics combination potentially a
continuous comments combination you
might need to take the integral right so
that needs to be handled but okay like
it's going to be a kind of combination
of distributions in the level set and
since by assumptions convex that means
gamma conditional and bads will also
have the same property value okay so
almost by definition
and the second direction is virtually
the same as we saw for the counter
example for variances so that's
essentially the
only way that you can fail in general
right so let's say Aaron's distribution
has uh value V and George's distribution
is value v such that
um our convex level sets condition is
falsified for you know the V uh valued
level sets Okay so this is V is the
level set of the property that falsifies
the fact that it has convex level sets
okay and there's going to be some
weights Lambda and one minus Lambda says
that you combine you know some two
points right so let's say it's Jordan
Aaron in that level set and their
combination does not actually give you
the same value V okay so we write that
down and we see that this is exactly the
example that we saw before except it
says the same thing now for
um any property gamma that doesn't have
convex level sets not just uh variances
okay
so this is an if and only if connection
um yeah virtually no further uh
conditions that we should require here
but now
let's actually turn into property
elicitation
and this this is sort of like the
central notion that like you know I
haven't
the title of my talk so I better explain
what that means so uh a property gamma
is elicitable if there's a loss function
called a proper loss right but proper
for this specific property okay not
proper in general uh such that
uh no matter what underlying label
distribution you're faced with
you take the expectation of that loss
with respect to like any value that you
want to plug in as your guess for what
the true property value is and then the
true property value for that
distribution will in fact be the
minimizer of this loss okay so here if
you replace this p with with some like
empirical samples from P that's going to
be exactly empirical risk minimization
right you sample a bunch from your data
you minimize some loss and that's what
you get okay relatedly a property is
identifiable if there's if there's
essentially A first order condition that
you can solve for right so
um identification function V that also
takes in your guess and the label and
its expected value should be zero
exactly when you guessed exactly the
right property value okay
and actually this does not always have
to be the first story condition because
maybe your loss is not very well behaved
so like people in the properly station
Community deal with this extensively
okay
yep
so the properties I mean you can you can
you can still have the same setup so for
example
um in your talk right you gave the
example of you know uh the L1 loss right
that happens to elicit you know the
binary definition of a medium that
happens to not be interesting as much as
you know the actual label mean right it
says if you're probably greater than one
half then you know that's what you get
um so yeah for any property that is well
defined is sensible to Define on
um yeah binary distributions you can
still have the same setup
um yeah
this thresholding is that uh it's a
little problem in your definition
yeah so so yeah whenever whenever you
claim that I can elicit some
professional something uh for any
underlying distribution using this
particular loss that means that it's an
illicitable property with respect to
that specific proper loss this is also
the definition of proper nausea yeah so
so there's also there's also something
that's called like just proper loss not
proper respect to any property but
proper with respect to the entire
distribution and that would be an object
that elicits the entire distribution so
the binary case is pretty difficult to
wrap your head around because there's
some losses that are proper just for
means you know for higher label space
dimensionalities Also happen to your
list of the entire distribution for
binary label right so the boundary is
blurred but yeah you can essentially
consider one of the following tasks
either you try to elicit a full
distribution which is incredibly High
cards for non-binary cases or you try to
elicit let's say one statistic of your
underlying distribution right in for
each of those cases if there is a loss
that does that consistently for any
underlying true stem that's good
can you give examples of like how to
list the experience
so you cannot elicit fear x's and that's
that's like the that's like that follows
from the next so this is this is an
incredibly difficult theorem to prove
even though it sounds almost uh evident
from like our discussion so far the
listed ability is equivalent to having
Comics level sets it's equivalent to
identifiability so in fact experiences
uh do not even have a lot of civilizes
them that's why in practice if you want
to know the variance of your data you
first elicit the means using let's say
the squared loss right or whatever other
loss that illicits means and then you
say okay let's go ahead and compute the
variance given that we think we know the
mean from that let's write two-step
procedure there okay so yeah variances
don't have such losses quantiles do for
quantiles this fold the pinball loss for
example that's the generalization of uh
the L1 loss right slightly weighted
um but yeah so there's this
characterization it's it's yeah it's
very non-trivial to show but it
basically says that a continuous killer
statistic satisfies all these at once or
none of them and so that means through
the convex level sets uh equivalents
which have showed that uh a property is
possible to calibrate in the sense that
the underlying truth is calibrated if
and only if the property is illicitable
and yeah I'm leaving out some uh hairy
details that uh you know yeah are in the
paper but uh they should not concern us
mostly
um okay but how would you actually
design a multi-calibration algorithm for
this so since I introduced the notion of
identifiability and time to use it so
far that's actually what what's what I'm
going to use right now right uh and
actually this first story condition this
identification function essentially
works as a generalized Checker so for
any group value pair you say okay let's
check what's happening and uh you know
if my if my first story condition is
very non-zero like really non-zero then
I'm going to go ahead and fix that up
okay and the convergence analysis of
this procedure basically involves saying
that uh the proper loss that the list is
this rule will be our potential function
and since we're essentially fixing
fixing up with gradients all the time
that means that we're you know moving
towards minimizing that loss so that's
the general picture of what really
happens so yeah for for means it was the
squared loss that was lurking behind the
salary as the as the object was the
potential function for quantiles is
going to be some sort of pinnable loss
and so on and so forth okay so a
negative results and uh I'm not going to
Define this very wide class of risks
other than showing a picture that I drew
it's this is my neat handwriting so yeah
I'm gonna not gonna
say anything else about this uh class
other than uh perhaps the fact that it
operates by saying okay like let's say
you have a variable
um and let's say we want to sort of
distort uh the behavior of this variable
in the tails to sort of say Okay I want
to put more emphasis on like bad
outcomes that happen you know when the
variable is very large right and so then
I can like over emphasize those outcomes
or I can underemphasize right a
distortion function is any function that
starts at zero zero and goes to zero one
and sort of re-weights uh your
distribution and this is a pretty rich
class of measures includes means and
quantiles includes lots of spectral risk
measures uh uh conditional value at risk
and so on and so forth and
so as an illustration of sort of like
how we can benefit from property
illustration problem station can benefit
from us we take results a very elegant
result has a very nice proof actually
other than means and quantiles like all
these Distortion risk measures for like
any Distortion functions that you want
you might want to be interested in do
not have convex level sets so it very
neatly tells us even bypassing the like
listability is equivalent to Comics
levels that's characterization very
neatly and directly tells us that we
cannot multi-calibrate any further
Distortion risks other than the ones
that we already can means in quantiles
and it's just you know a sample result
right you can come up with more such
results uh multi-calibration is not
Universal like that's one evidence
and let me briefly say what happens uh
for the mean variance case sort of like
as a more General picture to actually
get insight into this so
um I know that some previous papers
um basically assume that uh you know
maybe it's because variances are linear
conditional means so we should always
find you know some like other statistic
that like linearizes you and that's the
only way out but in reality uh sort of
from our discussion so far
um it's um it's actually evident that
the condition is slightly different it's
that
a property is conditionally elicitable
if there's another property that is
itself elicitable and this new property
gamma that may not be listed by itself
is listable on every level set of the
underlying list of the property okay and
so this is an example of what what could
happen so like let's say this is the
listable properties level set here their
convex is the non-alissable property
conditional on each of the level sets of
the first property this is a convex
object now there's non-convexity as soon
as you combine level sets right so this
like means and there's like variances in
general okay
and actually uh yeah the same general
family of algorithms will work you
multi-calibrate something that is
illicitable then you say okay let's
assume that you know I got this and let
me multi-calibrate Gamma One Condition I
want our predictor for gamma knots and
then we're like okay now gamma not needs
to be recalibrated then we repeat that
until conversions okay
so uh yeah I'm just gonna say that uh
I've been talking about the batch
setting right now but uh all of this
applies to the online adversarial case
where you're receiving like sequences of
data and whatever definition of
multi-calibration I've been using so far
will also be enforceable in the online
case uh with the you know batch
distribution of data being replaced with
the empirical distribution over your uh
sequence of data that you see okay and
the algorithm will be different of
course because now you need to sort of
like hedge right in this online setting
and so it's uh it can be derived from a
certain result sort of like sort of like
is a crossbreed of black hole
approachability and exponential weights
okay and so some summary and
perspectives on this so illicible
properties right are equivalent to
having convex level sets and from this
we derive the existential truths that
you know these properties are possible
to multi-calibrate these aren't you know
the isn't calibrated through
identifiability right which is the first
order condition of listability
essentially we derive the actual
algorithms for doing so okay
there is lots of negative results that
you could obtain and I showed you this
one right uh you know there's like so
many risks out there and only so many of
them are actually useful for us to look
at
um
and it's sometimes possible to escape
not a listenability when you have
listability conditional on some other
statistics that you are fortunate to
have through other losses
okay so
um to brief remarks to conclude first
off uh sort of like to intrusively
relate this to Omni prediction
um wonderfully described in British talk
um
in Omni prediction you mostly care about
loss minimization so your central object
that you desire to study is losses and
then what what you do is sort of you
hardness the power of multi-calibration
uh type techniques to sort of like
summarize your data and all sorts of
multi-valid ways such that then you can
do some data free post-processing to
optimize all the losses that you want
and even more okay so today we took
almost an opposite perspective we
started with the statistics that we
wanted to elicit about the data and sort
of like try to answer the question like
do you actually have losses to minimize
to obtain those statistics because right
this it could be an arbitrary map like
nobody says that there should be a loss
and it should be a listable right
um and I'm hoping there will be lots of
fruitful overlap between these two
perspectives
and finally
um to sort of relate uh to a point from
Michael's tutorial on Monday right so an
actual question is given sort of a class
of properties that we want to be outcome
and distinguishable with respect to
right so how do we come up with you know
distinguishers that will help us
efficiently do so
and
uh for at least one dimensional
statistics uh of your distribution the
answer uh is pretty simple and
comprehensive if that statistic is
illicitable then you take the
identification function you take its
expectation if that's too big on you
know some of your data then you sort of
like fire up alarms and you fix that and
you keep going otherwise if gamma is not
elicitable then actually there is no
sense in talking about oi as it's
commonly defines and you know you cannot
have neither a distinguisher nor you
know outcome listability per se okay
all right I'll finish here thank you
very much
[Applause]
um in the interest of time let's take
any further questions offline and at the
coffee break and we'll meet back here at
3 30. okay I want to emphasize that the
wrong session did not be recorded
more free it's supposed to be fun and
then because of yours first
we'll see I need for the First Act we
made the volunteers to attack
okay